so these circus continues apparently
attorney-client privilege is just not a
thing anymore at all it seems so michael
cohen president Trump's former lawyers
on Capitol Hill today testifying at a
House hearing testifying against the
president
now Cohen of course is is a known liar
and he's going to jail for lying so to
any thinking person his credibility is
shall we say a little bit compromised
but nonetheless he supposedly comes with
evidence of illegal activity on the part
of the president but in fact it seems
that he he succeeds more in exonerating
President Trump than he does in
implicating him in any kind of actual
criminal conduct and most of his
testimony revolves around allegations of
non criminal conduct anyway so looking
at his at his opening statement just
just to give you an example he says
stuff like this he says mr. Trump is an
enigma he is complicated as am i he has
both good and bad as do we all
but the bad far outweighs the good and
since taking office he has become the
worst version of himself he is capable
of behaving kindly but he is not kind he
is capable of committing acts of
generosity but he is not generous he is
capable of being loyal but he is
fundamentally disloyal Donald Trump is a
man who ran for office to make his brand
great not to make our country great he
had no desire or intention to lead this
nation only to market himself and to
build his wealth and his power mr. Trump
would often say this campaign was going
to be the greatest infomercial in
political history he had never expected
to win the primary he never expected to
win the general election the campaign
for him was always a marketing
opportunity now that last part there
about he didn't expect to win it was
just marketing we'll get to this a
minute but that's actually significant I
think that's a very significant point in
favor of of Trump at least at least in
favor of Trump's innocence in regards to
any criminal conduct now it's not in
favor of Trump's integrity if it's true
when it comes to criminal conduct I
think that that's actually going to be a
point in his favor well we'll get to
that in a minute but most of what you
what you heard there and there's a lot
of this kind of stuff in his opening
statement it's the kind of thing that
you put in an attack ad when you're
running against him in 2020 which of
course is the point of this whole
hearing it's just to get is to get
fodder for attack ads to get is to get
this stuff
it's just video clips there's little
bits of footage that you can then put
into a montage when you're running
against him and to show what a bad guy
he is just as long and that's obvious of
course but just as I just want to make
sure we're all on the same page and we
realize what this is about because even
if it's true that Trump is an enigma
who's more focused on his brand that is
not a criminal allegation and if these
hearings meant anything which they don't
but if they did they wouldn't provide a
forum for people to make subjective
statements like that Cohen also Cohen
gets into talking about Trump ran a
campaign based on division and hatred
again this is fine I mean that's that's
the kind of thing that you say about
about a politician if you're trying to
damage them politically fine but that's
not what this hearing should be about
Cohen also alleges racism he says he
says while we were once driving through
a struggling neighborhood in Chicago he
commented that only black people could
live that way and he told me that black
people would never vote for him because
they were too stupid I have no idea if
that's true or not obviously has no
evidence of it this is coming from
someone again who's going to jail for
lying it strikes me as made-up I mean I
don't know i don't know Trump personally
I have no clue what he says behind
closed doors but it strikes me as the
kind of thing that somebody would make
up but who knows
and then he alleges dishonest and
self-serving conduct from years before
Trump was elected he says mr. Trump
directed me to find a straw bidder to
purchase a portrait of him that was
being auctioned at art Hamptons
and the objective was to ensure that his
portrait which was going to be auctioned
last would go for the highest price of
any portrait that afternoon the portrait
was purchased by the fake bidder for
$60,000 mr. Trump directed the Trump
Foundation which is supposed to be a
charitable organization to repay the
fake bidder despite keeping the art for
himself please see exhibit so then he
gives his he gives his uh his evidence
of this and it should come as no
surprise that one of my common
responsibilities was that mr. Trump
directed me to call business owners many
of whom were small businesses that were
owed money for their services and told
them no payment or a reduced payment
will be coming when I advised mr. Trump
of my success
he actually reveled in it so this is
stuff from before he was president
misleading inappropriate the idea that
Trump would buy his own portrait that I
do find perfectly believable but it's
not exactly grounds for a peon
Pietschmann is it what are the grounds
for impeachment I mean that's supposed
to be the point here right this is
supposed to be
you've got the guys lawyer okay you've
got the this is so this is Trump's fixer
this is his personal lawyer the media
keeps telling us well that he knows
where the bodies are buried
okay I mean yeah this is this is this is
quite a coup on the part of the
Democrats you've got this the president
that you hate you have his lawyer now
spilling the beans how often do you have
an opportunity like that to get all the
dirt on on your on your political
opponent and so he should have some
really good stuff right if Trump is
guilty of breaking laws of Trump as a
criminal this is the guy who will know
it and he should be able to give you
some really good dirt so what's the good
dirt good for the Democrats anyway here
are the big a queue this the supposed
bombs that Cohen drops are first we have
this who says you need to know that mr.
Trump's personal lawyers reviewed and
edited my statement to Congress about
the timing of the MA
scout our negotiations before I gave it
to be clear mr. Trump knew of and
directed the Trump Moscow negotiations
throughout the campaign and lied about
it he lied about it because he never
expected to win the election he also
lied about it because he stood to make
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
Moscow real estate project and so I lied
about it too because mr. Trump had made
clear to me through his personal
statements to me that we both knew were
false and through his lies to the
country that he wanted me to lie and we
made it clear and he made it clear to me
because his a personal attorneys
reviewed my statement before I gave it
to Congress now this is interesting the
bit there at the end about how Trump
wanted him to lie we'll get back to that
in a minute
but what did he just reveal here I mean
think about this for a minute
he revealed that Trump was directing the
not the Moscow negotiations that is he
was trying to get a Trump Tower built in
Moscow which nothing criminal about that
when you're a real estate developer
you're trying to get buildings built
across the world
okay now Cohen says is what he says
right here he mentioned it before - he
didn't think Trump did not think that he
would become president he didn't think
he was gonna win what does that tell us
it tells us that Trump was not trying to
leverage the presidency for financial
gain he wasn't trying to get a deal
going with Russia on the basis of him
becoming president so it wasn't like he
was saying hey guys let us bill he
wasn't saying to Russia let us build
this this thing you know in Moscow and
then when I'm in the Oval Office I'll
scratch your back - now that would be
illegal that would be corruption that
would be impeachable if Trump was using
the power of his office to enrich
himself and enrich his business and if
this was all him running for president
was just some kind of ploy not for him
to you know get attention to himself
which I mean that's that's part of the
reason why anyone runs for president but
if the ploy was I want to become
president so that I can then
you know make these business deals and
enrich myself well then okay now you got
something you would need evidence of it
but now at least there's an accusation
that is quite serious but that's exactly
what Cohen is not alleging he says that
Trump didn't think he was going to win
so he was just trying to keep his
options open and his business going
until inevitably in his mind he lost
that that is very significant this one
little bit here this this one line about
Trump thinking he wouldn't win is a game
changer I think because if that's true
and I believe that it is true in fact I
said I'm not just saying that now I said
many times this was it's not a secret I
was not a supporter of President during
the primary to put it mildly and one of
the things that I said about Trump
during the primary is I don't think he
wants to win I don't think he thinks
he's going to win I don't think he's in
this to win and according to Cohen this
is exactly correct and if that's the
case then it would seem to insulate
Trump from any accusation that he had
some scheme to leverage the presidency
now it's not good it's not good to run
for president when you don't even want
to win and you're just doing it for some
you know for to you know expand your
your you know reach and you're doing
that for the sake of your profile and
all of that now again that's very common
why do you think Bernie Sanders is
running for president Bernie Sanders ran
for president he was basically unknown
for the most part he's just some wacky
crazy senator up there in Vermont he
runs for president now he's known across
the country and what do you know he puts
out a book a couple years ago becomes a
best-seller and now he's a millionaire
this is what people do this is one of
the reasons if you ever wonder when you
see these people running for president
who have no chance of winning and
they're their polling like number 17 or
whatever and they stay in if you're
wondering why are they doing this it's
because of their profile and speak I
plan to write a book then they're gonna
make millions
so if
that's what Trump did it's not illegal
it's not even unusual I don't like it
but it would seem to protect him from
the more serious potential charge that
he was using the presidency and trying
to leverage it so now compare this for a
moment
to Hillary Clinton okay this is not what
about ISM it's not what I'm doing I'm
just trying to give you an example of
what it looks like when business
interests and political interests really
do collide to create actual corruption
okay I want to give you an example of
the kind of thing Trump apparently did
not do even according to his now enemy
so when Hillary Clinton was Secretary of
State she did leverage her authority in
that position to enrich the Clinton
Foundation her her own charitable
organization and we all understand by
the way Trump Foundation it's not about
charity the Clinton Foundation not about
charity all these politicians and
business people they have their
foundations supposed to be nonprofit or
charitable it's not what it's really
about we all know that but she did use
that power to enrich the Clinton
Foundation and to provide benefits to
its biggest donors so just for a quick
overview I'm gonna read two paragraphs
from an article in the National Review
back in 2016 written by Andrew McCarthy
and this is what it says Hillary and her
husband former President Bill Clinton
operated the Clinton Foundation
ostensibly a charity the foundation was
a de facto fraud scheme to monetize
Hillary's power as Secretary of State
among other aspects of the Clintons
political influence the scheme involved
a the exchange of political favors
access and influence for millions of
dollars in donations be the
circumvention of campaign finance laws
that prohibit political Danette
donations by foreign sources see a
vehicle for mrs. Clinton to shield her
State Department email communications
from public and congressional scrutiny
while she and her husband exploited the
fundraising potential of her position
and D a means for Clinton insiders to
receive private-sector compensation and
explore lucrative employment
opportunities while drawing
taxpayer-funded government salaries
while the foundation did perform some
charitable work this camouflaged the
fact that contributions were
substantially diverted to pay lavish
salaries and underwrite luxury travel
for Clinton on insiders contributions
skyrocketed to one hundred and twenty
six million dollars in 2009 the year
that mrs. Clinton arrived at Foggy
Bottom breathtaking sums were donated by
high rollers and foreign governments
that had crucial business before the
State Department along with those
staggering donations came a spike in
speaking opportunities and fees for Bill
Clinton of course disproportionate
payments and gifts to a spouse are
common ways of bribing public officials
which is why for example high-ranking
government office holders must reveal
their spouses income and other asset
information on their financial
disclosure forms while there are other
egregious transactions the most
notorious corruption episode of center
of secretary Clinton's tenure involves
the State Department's approval of a
deal that surrendered fully one-fifth of
the United States uranium mining
capacity to vladimir putin's
anti-american thug accuracy in russia
okay now this is just to give you an
example this is what corruption looks
like this is classic this is just
classic corrupt if you look up
corruption dictionary that's basically
what you get it's classic stuff here
grade-a corruption the accusations about
Trump don't look like that even if you
believe everything that Cohen says which
you can't but even if you did you come
away with the impression that Trump is
kind of a huge jerk
and a bit of a bumbling idiot and
extremely conceited and he lies a lot to
the media to the public and so on and
that's if you take everything the Trump
that Cohen says as gospel even if you
did that that's the most you can draw
from it now here's the other supposed
blockbuster revelation it says in this
is back to Cohen's statement it says in
July 2016 days before the Democratic
convention I was in mr. Trump's office
when his Secretary of when he
secretary announced that Roger stone was
on the phone mr. Trump but Mr Stoops mr.
stone on the speakerphone
mr. stone told mr. Trump that he had
just gotten off the phone with Julian
Assange and that Mr Assange told mr.
stone that within a couple of days there
would be a massive dump of emails that
would damage Hillary Clinton's campaign
mr. Trump responded by stating to the
effect of wouldn't that be great all
right so he doesn't say that Trump
directed anyone to hack the emails or
that he asked anyone to leak the emails
or that he had any hand in it at all
which again now that would be a crime if
Trump somehow organized the hacking of
Clinton's emails now you've got a
serious crime on your hands but that's
not even what Cohen says he says that
says someone called him and told him
that in a few days this was all gonna be
coming out and Trump was happy about
that
okay he I said I don't even understand
why what are we suppose how am I
supposed to get to that so someone
completely separate from Trump hacked
the emails and then some other third
party completely separate from Trump
WikiLeaks was gonna was gonna put them
out and Trump was happy so of course he
was happy that you're running it you're
running against someone and you find out
that there's any embarrassing
information coming out about them what
do you expect them to say oh no well
this is we need to alert them right away
we need to alert the Clinton campaign so
they can be prepared for this this isn't
fair no I well certainly I want a beater
in the election but I don't want her to
be embarrassed that's not what I want
is that really what I was expected
that's exactly what anyone would say
when you're running for office and you
find out that other it's gonna be
something to something coming out about
your opponent okay good great awesome
yeah that's what I would say if I was
running against somebody
it's just that is such a weak and the
media is taking this and they're
plastering it everywhere making
headlines
out of it Trump says that would be great
when he finds out about WikiLeaks okay
and in the end when it comes time for
the rubber to meet the road and for
Cohen to really get to the meat of
things and talk about actual criminal
behavior he does the opposite for one he
admits that Trump never told him to lie
to Congress he says and I quote mr.
Trump did not directly tell me to lie to
Congress that's not how he operates he
says that Trump implied that he wanted
him to lie with facial expressions and
with indirect Commons in that sort of
thing so he says that Trump you know
gave the impression he didn't say it but
he just gave the impression that that's
what he wanted I'm going to do and so
Cohen did but that is that's pretty weak
sauce that's that's not enough to
justify any kind of impeachment or
anything and then there's this Cohen
says questions have been raised about
whether I know of direct evidence that
mr. Trump or his campaign colluded with
Russia I do not I want to be clear but I
have my suspicions and then he goes on
to talk about his suspicions but he has
no evidence or knowledge of collusion
and that's what this was all originally
supposed to be about right
isn't that mean that's what this was all
supposed to be about does it Trump
colluded with Russia and now you've got
the guy I mean this is the guy who know
the media says he knows where all the
bodies are buried he knows he knows all
the bad stuff he's got all the dirt he's
got nothing left to lose he's going to
jail so if anyone with direct knowledge
if anyone would have direct knowledge of
something like this and be willing to
say it it would be him and yet he says
no I don't know anything about that
I have no direct knowledge so I mean if
if Russian collusion was supposed to be
the big crime the big scandal then the
headline of this
of his testimony is that according to
this testimony he has no knowledge of
Russian collusion so what do we do with
all this I suspect that we do nothing
with it if you already hated Trump going
into this then you're still gonna hate
him and you're gonna see this as
vindication of your hatred for him if
you loved him then you'll still love him
and you'll just dismiss all this because
hey this is a liar and a lot of what
he's saying is not criminal and so on if
if you like me or you know take a more
kind of I think balanced approach then
you'll probably look at this testimony
and you'll say okay he alleges some
things that if true are morally
reprehensible but particularly the
racist comments but we don't know if
they're true they're almost certainly
not completely true given the source and
they're probably not completely false
because this is coming from a guy who
would know the dirt and Trump probably
has some dirt on him
so probably not everything you said was
was false so what was true what was
false who knows a lot of audial edges is
not criminal so there's not much we can
do that would do with this on balance I
think that's what if you take more
balanced approach that's kind of where
you'll end with it and here's the other
thing
it's the Democrat Party that is
obviously trying to destroy Trump here
right they're the ones organizing this
whole campaign obviously so anyone with
a moral compass has to take that into
account we have to take into account the
fact that the Democrat Party is an evil
institution an institution full of
people who support infanticide people
who support socialism people who support
the legal persecution of Christians
people who have no qualms about
organizing smear campaigns and trying to
destroy their political opponents with
blatant falsehoods and lies as was the
case with Cavanaugh so
we have to factor that in you know there
there are a lot of Republicans there are
a lot of conservatives I should say a
lot of conservatives who are
disillusioned with the Republican Party
and have been for a long time and a lot
of those same Republican servitors don't
like Trump or even actively really
dislike him but they cannot align
themselves with the Democrats and they
feel morally obligated to support the
opposition to support whoever opposes
the the Democrats which in this case
would be Trump in his administration
because the Democrats are just so evil
because especially the Democrats support
fund facilitate the slaughter of of
millions of babies you know someone
asked me today
when I giving my impressions of Cohen's
opening statement on Twitter and making
all the points that I've made here and
somebody said well you're just you know
you're just taking from side because
you're pro-life and the Democrats are
pro-abortion
well that's not true you know I'm giving
my honest analysis of what Cohen had to
say so that's not true
but does that factor in to my approach
to Trump yeah of course it does how
could it not I don't I don't pretend
otherwise I'm not ashamed to say that of
course I have to keep in mind here that
the people who are trying to destroy
Trump are not only blatant liars and
have shown themselves to be that but
these are really evil people who and
there are other things besides the
abortionist issue but I don't even need
to get beyond that I mean these are
people who if they had it their way and
if they controlled everything abortion
would be legal through every stage of
presidents through every stage of
pregnancy and beyond these are people
who facilitate fund support the mass
slaughter of millions of babies just
evil evil stuff and so that means that I
will I'll never take their side on
anything that doesn't mean that I'm
always gonna defend Trump on it I've
criticized Trump plenty of times if I
think Trump is wrong about something I'm
gonna criticize him it all even
criticize them very harshly as I have
done plenty of times over the last two
years and before that but I'll never
align myself with the Democrats but I'll
stake out a third position where you've
got Trump the Democrats and I'll be over
here I'll do that sometimes but I'm
never gonna go over here with them never
ever I could never do that
III I think any moral person has an
obligation to not do that because of how
evil these people are and because of
what their intentions are and what they
want to do all right what else I wanted
to mention this this briefly just
because it's a subject that's near and
dear to my heart as you know because
I've talked about it many times on the
show and I've written about it so I
can't I have to say something when this
is when this is a subject people are
talking about a writer for New York
magazine Yashar Ally wrote a long
Twitter thread about ADHD yesterday
describing his own experiences with the
so called disorder and the thread went
massively viral ADHD was the top
trending topic on Twitter yesterday you
know across across the country I believe
as everybody was talking about ADHD and
describing their own experiences with
this alleged affliction although I did
kind of find out a sort of ironic that
you're sure I wrote this he wrote such a
long twitter thread about ADHD and so
those of us with ADHD you know we're
like what I can't read all that that's
too much now as I've shared plenty of
times in the past I myself definitely
without question have what is described
as ADHD that is if I went to a doctor
and I described described my symptoms to
the doctor I would certainly be
diagnosed with it and they would give me
whatever drugs I asked for
leading to this to this disorder there's
no question about that yet I do not
believe that ADHD exists and I want to
explain what I mean by that because I
think that there's a there's kind of a
false paradigm that goes on with this
discussion when I say that that I don't
think ADHD exists what I mean by that is
I don't think it's a disorder I fully
believe that ADHD type personalities
exist I know that firsthand I live with
it every day but the word disorder is
embedded into ADHD it's right there in
the acronym and that's what I take take
issue with so the the ADH part I don't
have a problem with that attention
deficit hyperactivity whatever yes it's
when you attack that D on to it that I
have a problem now if you if we were to
change that D to something else if we
were to say attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder I have a problem
with that as I've tried to argue over
the years I think we've committed and I
think it's such an important point so I
go back to whenever I can we have
committed a category error with regards
to this issue and we commit the same
error in my opinion with many other
alleged mental disorders and the error
is philosophical this is a philosophical
question it's not a medical one so
anytime I talk about something like this
and someone says you're not a doctor you
can't say that what do you what do you
know where did you you where did you get
your medical degree there Matt well
first of all where's your medical degree
you know 99% of the people when you try
to share an opinion about a topic like
this 99% of the people who shout at you
you're not a doctor your opinion doesn't
count
99% of them are not doctors either yet
they have no problem sharing their own
opinion which is not based on any kind
of medical degree so what they really
what they really mean to say is if
you're not a doctor you're not allowed
to share your
piñon about this unless you agree with
me in which case you can in which case
your opinion is totally fine it so it is
completely credible and based on you
know research and logic and all that so
that's what they mean and that's that's
a that's a pet peeve of mine that it's
kind of a separate issue but this thing
people do where they pretend not to take
your opinion seriously if you don't have
the right credentials and the problem
with that is most of the time they do it
hypocritically because they don't really
care about the credentials what they
really care about is the fact that you
disagree with them if you didn't
disagree they wouldn't care about the
credentials but even aside from that the
credentials aren't important if someone
is saying something that's true it
doesn't matter what credentials they
have for saying it it's true if somebody
is making a logical argument then you as
a thinking person should engage with the
logic of their argument regardless of
their credentials they could be an
illiterate person who's never read a
book in their life but if they make a
logical argument you should be able to
engage with it and if there are logical
problems with it point out the logical
problems if you can't point to any
specific problem then falling back on
hey you don't have the right credentials
for this that's just intellectual
cowardice and it's a it's obfuscation
it's deflection but the bigger point
here is that this is not a medical
question nobody denies that that people
exist who are easily distracted who have
trouble focusing who have trouble
staying on task who have minds that go
in a million directions at once okay I
know what that's like you know and and
no one denies that the question is is is
whether that is a disordered way to be
in other words the philosophical
question is should people be that way in
the next question or the question before
that is how is a person supposed to be
what is a normal person so we say well
that's AB
normale okay well number one what is
normal what is the normal mind who is
the normal person what is the ideal that
we're all supposed to be striving for
and even if you could prove that there
is such a thing as a normal person and a
normal brain and a normal mind which you
can't because that doesn't exist but
even if it does who says that there's
anything wrong with being abnormal now
what I would say is that is that
hundreds of millions of people have an
ADHD disposition including millions of
people in school and it is but it is not
a disorder and the fact that hundreds of
millions of people have it is kind of an
indication that it's actually not that
abnormal at all now obviously if
hundreds of millions of people if
there's some sort of flu epidemic going
around and hundreds of millions of
people are dying from it then the fact
that hundred million hundreds of million
people have it and it's and it's normal
in that sense that doesn't mean that
it's not that it's not an illness of
course in that case it is but that's
totally different because the flu
actively physically harms you no matter
what context you're in that's the thing
it's not like the flu is only harmful if
you're in school and you're trying to
complete a worksheet or the flu is
especially harmful at work no the flu is
equally harmful no matter where you are
no matter what you do for a living
matter how old you are well it does
depend on how old your but it's it's
it's harmful no matter what context
you're in the thing about ADHD and the
same for legitimate brain diseases like
like for instance dementia if you have
dementia they can look at a brain scan
they see you have it and you're gonna
have it no matter where you are you'll
have it on a train you'll have it on a
plane you'll have it in in a school
classroom you'll have it on a job you'll
have it everywhere because that's the
way that a disease works ADHD is not
like that ADHD a diagnosis of ADHD
depends largely on context it depends on
does it interfere with you
your schooling if you're a kid does it
interfere with your job does it make
this and that thing in life more
complicated or difficult but just
because something a certain disposition
or personality makes it difficult to
complete a certain task that doesn't
mean that it's a disease that doesn't
mean that it's a disorder that doesn't
mean that you're ill whether you have a
mental problem it could mean it could
mean many other things it could mean
that that there's something wrong with
the thing that you're you're with with
the context in other words we say that
you know all these kids aren't able to
focus in school aren't able to achieve
what they need to do in a school
environment and so that means that they
all have mental disorders and we got to
put them on drugs well I would suggest
that it's no the kids aren't the ones
who dis disordered it's the school
environment that is disordered if the
school system operates in such a way
that it can only operate if millions of
kids are on drugs then what that tells
me is not that those kids have a
disorder it's that there's something
wrong with the school system there is
something wrong with the system
so maybe we have decided that everybody
especially kids the everyone should be
the sort of person who can sit at a desk
for hours a day and complete busy work
and read this and fill that out and just
do that four hours a day with four hours
a day with very little exercise with
very little physical activity we've
decided that everybody should be able to
do that including kids and what I'm
saying is maybe we're wrong maybe just
some people aren't built for that maybe
that's not natural
maybe it's perfectly natural and normal
for there to be all for there to be
millions of people billions even who
really can't do that did you start made
for it you just aren't those kinds of
people
and that's the point again we we have
this is a philosophical determination
that we have made that everybody should
be the kind of person who can succeed in
these sorts of confined very calm kinds
of environments where there's a lot of
memorization and regurgitation we've
decided that everybody should be that
kind of person and I think and that is a
that's a philosophical position that
people have taken I think that it's it's
it's wrong it is completely wrong
so maybe rather than you know treating
everyone like they have a disorder maybe
we need maybe there needs to be a whole
I hate to use the phrase maybe there
needs to be a whole paradigm shift maybe
we need to change these systems
maybe we all like diversity right maybe
we need to allow for some diversity of
personality and in education and in
every other walk of life
maybe we should allow for people to be
all different kinds of ways and to have
all kinds of different personalities
maybe that's okay all right
I want to move ahead to two emails here
a lot of interesting ones Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com is the is the email address a
couple emails reacting to our to a
conversation yesterday we had this is
from Kate says hi Matt I'm a big fan but
I think you went too far in your podcast
today by arguing that every Democrat is
evil based on the born alive bill I
agree that voting no on the bill is evil
but I don't think you can know if people
voting Democrat are evil based on that I
hate the Articles that argue Republicans
are evil because they're directly or
indirectly supporting Trump if you don't
like being painted it painted as evil on
a single issue that I don't think it's
fair to call all Democrats evil either
after all there were a few who voted yes
well Kate
I appreciate that you're being
charitable and I understand that I did
allow for the fact that there are when
it comes to just average everyday
Democrats there are plenty who are
extremely ignorant and so they might not
really know just how extreme their party
has gotten on issues like abortion they
may may they might not have even heard
of this vote the media is trying to
cover it up as the media always runs
cover for the Democrats pro-abortion
extremism so I and I allow for that
there are plenty of ignorant people my
point though is that there is no excuse
for that ignorance if you are ignorant
in the information age you are without
excuse and if you're going to support a
certain political party it is your moral
obligate moral and intellectual
obligation to become informed about that
party and what it stands for and and you
know the positions that it takes the
policies that it supports and your
knowledge should encompass where the
party is today not where the party was
forty years ago but where it is today
and so that is your obligation and
anyone who has failed to fulfill that
obligation
you know that they're not evil
necessarily but I do think that it is a
that it is a moral flaw on their part as
well as an intellectual one but for
everyone else like if you know that this
party supports infanticide and this
party supports funds facilitates the
slaughter of millions of children then
and yet you still support it then I
think you're just not a good person and
you couldn't prove you could be you
couldn't get better I hope you do I'm
not saying it's it's hopeless for you
but to intentionally and knowingly
support the mass slaughter of children I
don't see how anyone could do that and
still be in any sense a good or decent
person to me it's just that simple
as far as that you know there were three
Democrats who voted against it and I'm
glad that they did but again
they stay they have a moral obligation
they should be what is
leave the party it's not enough anymore
to just disagree with the party on on
these issues but then stay aligned with
them you need to leave there is no moral
excuse anymore for staying aligned with
this party that supports the slaughter
of millions of children a year this is
from hope he says she sorry well I guess
I hope I guess I should not presume to
place a gender on you one way or another
hey Matt so somebody on your show
brought up weed and you mentioned that
you don't know how and you don't know
much about it I'm a believer who is
firmly against weed and know a lot about
it due to personal experience one hit
can get you high many people claim I
smoked because it helps me sleep you
will get no REM sleep while high
therefore you will not process
information and it will remain in
short-term memory until that gets to
full and the information is then dumped
also weed may not be physically
addicting but it is very emotionally
addicting on a more biblical note where
the modern Bible says sorcery in many
places the Greek root is pharmakeia so
quite frequently the Scriptures list
using drugs as bad in Galatians 5 it is
in the same list as drunkenness anyway I
have many unprovable theories as to why
it's so bad so I will just leave it at
this thank you for taking the time and
please don't ever endorse smoking weed
the last thing we need is more Christian
households letting that in oh and last
note it's very easy to get contact hi
so--that's hopes opinion now I'm gonna
go to another email this is from someone
who just signs their name listener
listener says to answer your question
about marijuana it is much safer than
alcohol it is not addictive it won't
destroy your liver
you can't die from marijuana poisoning
and yes plenty of people smoke socially
and don't get high it just relaxes as
you said about alcohol marijuana occurs
naturally God made it there must be a
reason for that and finally this is an
interesting this is kind of a longer
discussion but alright I wanted to maybe
I'll maybe I should save this for
tomorrow the question is this is from
Heidi he says hi Matt I had an
interesting argument with a friend
recently she was arguing that sometimes
it can be morally acceptable for a
person to steal if someone is in a
desperate situation it can be morally Oh
okay for them to steal as long as they
are not physically hurting someone else
what do you think it's stealing
objectively morally wrong or is it only
wrong depending on the situation so is a
really interesting I've thought about
this before I had an argument with about
this exact issue with some people in my
family a couple years ago and it's an
interesting question and it's also very
relevant because it goes to this whole
idea that wealth is amoral and you know
it touches on all that kind of stuff and
the more I thought about this question I
realized that my answers gonna be very
long so I think I will save that for
tomorrow so tomorrow towards the end of
the show well well I'll try to tackle
that subject and we'll leave it there
for today thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed